en esta tabla nos están dando las
calificaciones del examen de mitad de
curso y del examen final lo llamaremos
parcial y final donde el azul
representará el examen de la mitad de
curso o el parcial y el amarillo
representará el final tenemos diferentes
preguntas que podemos contestar con esta
gráfica nosotros dentro de la gráfica
también tenemos aquí en el eje vertical
las calificaciones por puntos y en el
eje horizontal el nombre de cada
estudiante es decir tenemos por ejemplo
que ben tuvo 85 puntos en el examen de
mitad de curso o en el examen parcial y
en el examen final tuvo 90 puntos vamos
a contestar todas las preguntas que
tenemos aquí y poco a poco iremos
resolviendo cada una de ellas vamos a
empezar con cuál es la mediana para el
examen final la mediana se mide a través
de las calificaciones que tendremos así
es que vamos a poner aquí
calificaciones
y acomodaremos cada una de ellas nos
está pidiendo la mediana para el examen
final así es que tomaremos cada una de
las calificaciones del examen final ben
tuvo 90
nadie tuvo 90 también
kevin tuvo 95 al parecer fue un examen
final un tanto sencillo louis tuvo 90 o
pensemos que todos estudiaron mucho y
omar tuvo 70
para que nosotros podamos descubrir cuál
es la mediana primero vamos a organizar
estos valores del más pequeño al más
alto es decir en orden ascendente
así es que acomodaremos primero 70 luego
tendremos 90 otro 90 un 90 más y la
calificación más alta que fue 95
la mediana será justo el dato que queda
en el centro es decir separa la mitad de
un lado la otra y el dato que se
encuentre justo en el medio será la
mediana en caso de que tengamos dos
datos se sacará la media aritmética es
decir el promedio entre ambos números en
este caso si tenemos un número justo en
el centro y será 90 así es que nuestra
mediana será igual a 90 cuál es el rango
medio de las calificaciones parciales
vamos a hacer las calificaciones
parciales con azul para que también
logremos hacerle honor a las barras
azules el rango medio lo que nos dará es
la media aritmética entre el número más
alto y más pequeño que se encuentre
dentro de los valores vamos a escribir
los valores de las calificaciones del
examen parcial tendremos un 85 vamos a
ponerlo aquí
parciales
tuvimos 185
70 otra vez
y 70
podemos ver que el valor más pequeño fue
este 70 como valor y el más alto fue 85
vamos a marcarlos
y con esto tendremos entonces la forma
de sacar el rango medio de las
calificaciones parciales recuerda que el
rango medio nos está indicando la media
aritmética entre el valor más pequeño y
el más alto haremos lo siguiente 85
más 70
dividido entre dos para que podamos
sacar la media aritmética y esto nos
sumara 85 70 es igual a 155 entre 2 si
hacemos esa operación tendremos
15 entre 27 llevamos 115 entre 27 y
llevamos
110 entre 2 será igual a 5 por lo que
nuestro rango medio será 77.5 vamos bien
ahora nos preguntan cuál es la
calificación promedio de los estudiantes
en el examen final estos datos ya los
tenemos las calificaciones en el examen
final fueron 90 90 95 90 y 70 para que
nosotros saquemos el promedio vamos a
hacerlo con otro color anaranjado lo
queremos es sumar estos valores y
dividirlos entre la misma cantidad de
valores que se están sumando es decir
entre 5 en este caso vamos a escribir
entonces los valores 90 + 90 + 95 más 90
más 70 yo creo que podemos hacerlo con
la mente pero vamos a escribirlo de
cualquier manera 90 + 90 son 180 más 90
son 275 275 más 90
será igual a 365 y si a eso le sumamos
70 tendremos un total de 435
si eso lo vamos a dividir entre 5 para
tomar el promedio tendremos la siguiente
división
43 entre 5 es igual a 8 y nos sobran 3
35 entre 5 es igual a 7
por lo que tendremos que la calificación
promedio fue 87 ahora nos pregunta sobre
la moda y la moda la podemos distinguir
porque es el número o el valor que más
se repite dentro de nuestra base de
datos en este caso tenemos
90 90 y 90 tres veces tres veces de los
cinco datos totales por lo tanto el
número que más se repite es 90 y esa
será la moda
finalmente nos vamos con cuál es el
rango de las calificaciones parciales
este color amarillo casi no se ve vamos
a cambiarlo ok el rango es distinto del
rango medio recuerda que el rango medio
ya lo habíamos tenido y eso fue sacando
la media aritmética entre el número más
alto y el número más pequeño para que
nosotros saquemos el rango simplemente
haremos la diferencia entre el número
más grande que en este caso es 85
y el número más pequeño que en este caso
fue 70 simplemente va a ser la resta de
estos la diferencia 85 menos 70 es igual
a 15 y este es el rango nos está
diciendo que del valor más pequeño al
más grande nuestros datos se encuentran
en un rango para usar la palabra
correcta de 15 puntos simplemente
tenemos un rango de 15 puntos y con esto
hemos terminado todas las preguntas que
teníamos